[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
LED live we're thankful that you can
join us today we're going to be talking
about setting boundaries the application
of how do you set boundaries in your
life and there's a unique way that we
can look at that and today we have with
us denitra who we have had on our show
before and we also have Karen and Karen
has some experience in early childhood
education and of course we don't want to
forget Scotty who's been with this
program the ministry longer than anybody
oh so we're going to talk about applying
boundaries in our lives today so what is
it what what's this unique angle that
we're looking at Karen when we're
talking about applying boundaries well
it's just really exciting how the
sanctuary is uh something that a lot of
people don't understand or know maybe a
lot about but it does um apply very much
to
relationships and uh and uh and my
experience the Lord has led me in
working with children in early childhood
education and how to apply these
principles in working with all varieties
of personalities and challenges that
come in working with young young people
and so I'm just really excited excited
to be able to share that with you today
uh how the sanctuary is that Foundation
peace that keeps me solid on The Rock
when all kinds of winds blow and all
kinds of stress happens it's like I can
almost visualize that sanctuary and the
different steps that help to keep us
grounded in those uh tumultous times all
right I love it like the sanctuary um is
such an important topic I don't know if
it's talked about enough and and
especially a lot of different churches
maybe don't study this topic out very
well so I'm excited to hear what you
have to say but I I just want to make
this one comment as I listening to you
talk about relationships if you could
hang out with each one of the disciples
and we could go back and we could see
their personalities I bet you each one
was a personality that we would identify
with we would be like ah this guy right
here he's he's just like me and I Think
Jesus was a master at picking all of the
different challenges that would come by
putting all these people in a room
together and I mean look they're arguing
who's the best all the way up to the
night he gets crucified right so you
know Jesus Jesus knew firsthand what
it's like to have relationship
challenges and and this was his model
his plan on how to restore the
relationship and he did so well with
setting boundaries with all the
disciples each one of them setting
boundaries with them in a loving way
that's good point yeah very very true
that's that's neat because you think
think about the 12 disciples and also
the 12 tribes of Israel and I think
that's why he picked that because it
probably encompasses all the different
aspects of personality types that that
we fall under and God wants us to know
how to handle all kinds of personalities
some are very challenging for us and
others may be easier but God has the
pathway to handle whatever relationships
we find ourselves in yep so just a word
on the sanctuary then we have um some of
you may be new to that topic and so the
sanctuary was first introduced by Moses
and some of you may be familiar that he
spent time on the mountain yeah and God
came down and wrote the Ten Commandments
with his finger on the Ten Commandments
and that might be a familiar story to
many um you may not know that he stayed
there for 40 days and 40 nights and and
during that time the Israelites kind of
fell apart down below and but he was up
there he was really busy and what he was
doing was getting the sanctuary model
downloaded to him God was showing him
what the sanctuary was all about because
this is a copy of the Heavenly Sanctuary
which is God's house right and and our
house is about relationships right and
and people might not know you know if
you've never really looked into this
Topic in great detail um God told Moses
be careful that you follow everything
that I tell you to do so this this this
model of what happened here was not
Moses making some stuff up I mean it was
detailed because it came straight from
God so if you look at the difference in
in leadership between Moses and Joshua
have you ever gone through your Bible
and looked and there's a phrase that
occurs over and over and over again and
the Lord spoke to Moses or the Lord said
to Moes and then you look at the life of
Joshua there not a whole lot there
inter but God communicated a lot with
Moses a ton face to face like a
[Music]
friend would that be our experience and
the sanctuary model here and this there
are seven steps in the sanctuary are all
about getting close to Jesus getting to
understand and hear his voice better
because that's I know that's something
that I long for and maybe you are too
feeling that there's needs that you have
that only God can meet and the sanctuary
model is there for us to follow that
intimacy that we can have with Jesus
Christ when we think about the
importance of the sanctuary and how it
it means uh a relationship with Jesus we
need to understand that he created it
for the purpose of dwelling with us MH
yeah and so we can read in Exodus 25
verse um 8 that that was the purpose and
for those who have studied a lot about
the sanctuary it's easy to get very tied
up in what the priests did or didn't do
what the furniture was and all the
rights and services and all of that and
and God wants our generation to break
away from that and understand the deep
meaning behind the symbolism
of the sanctuary because this is God's
house this is his Heavenly sanctuary and
this is just a kindergarten picture for
us to try to grasp these deep deep
truths see you know this this is I like
this idea because I'm kind of a bottom
line kind of guy like I like it
simplified and you know what what
happened when we decided to eat the
fruit is God was in a relationship with
us he walked and talked with Adam and
Eve and that relationship was broken
because we chose to put a divide in
between us and God so God's got to try
to make a way for us to get back into
that relationship with him so so I just
want to kind of throw that out there
because I think that's the kind of like
the underlining thing that that we don't
want to lose or get distracted in all
these things this is simply God saying I
want a relationship back with you here's
how I do it yes yeah in the very
beginning there was a complete and full
agreement there was attachment and as a
result of sin and our decision to go
outside of the boundary line because
that that tree was a boundary um and
what what happened was now there's
disconnect now there's Detachment and so
the whole Sanctuary model is a plan to
get us to come into full agreement and
full attachment with God in every area
of Our Lives I mean there's so much
there's so much here
you can talk about this for a long long
long time yeah there's a an interesting
um thought process in Genesis 3 when
when that relationship is being broken
so the serpent he he makes these
offerings to e right you could you could
be like God you know you could have this
special knowledge of of Good and Evil um
you know these different things that
he's offering
and we look at those and we think okay
well you know he's he's he's tempting
her with these things but but there's so
much deeper of an
insinuation that
says God has not just given you life
he's given you he's given you many gifts
on this Earth but guess what there are
gifts that God does not want to give
you good gifts that God is not willing
to to
give so when that relationship is
broken
now God has to prove that he's willing
to give a gift that's so much greater
there's a gift that he will not
withhold but he has to do it under the
circumstances of somebody who's running
from them in
fear doesn't believe him
to their certain death and he's the only
one that can save
them but they're running away wow
terrified essentially that's the plight
of humanity yeah and yet God is trying
to reach them and say Here's a gift I
will not
withhold my
life yeah I tell God all the time when
I'm working through things I'm so sorry
that you got to do all this like I am so
sorry that I just can't just ploop and
just believe everything thing yeah you
know that you have to really woo me and
come into agreement with you because it
just wasn't that way and I and I'm so
grateful that we have a a gracious
Everlasting God that's willing to put
himself on display and that's what this
is all about is our willingness to
Humble ourselves so that we can minister
to others and that's really what he's
done for the last 6,000 years MH laid
himself down mhm laid laid down really
what his true intentions are and been
willing to walk us through this entire
path it's like God God is residing in
the most holy place right and he's going
you can inch closer and closer to me but
but you need to do it like
this absolutely absolutely because this
whole Sanctuary is about intimacy levels
of intimacy that grow greater and
greater and he's there calling us and
the sanctuary is all about Jesus and God
the father and God the Son and the Holy
Spirit all of them but every aspect of
what Jesus did for us by coming and
being human and now he offers it with
these seven complete steps of intimacy
with him and being able to hear his
voice better and better and that's what
he wanted to do and and this rescue plan
and even before he came as a man he had
this Sanctuary because he wanted to
dwell with them and that's what Exodus
258 says then let them make me a
sanctuary that I may dwell among them so
it wasn't for you know a number of
thousands years later that he came in
the human flesh but in the meantime he
had the sanctuary there and His shikina
glory was in the most holy place and he
was dwelling in their calling and then
there was also the cloud that was above
the most holy place so they could see
him as best as possible POS um it's a
closest he could come it boggles the
mind it boggles the mind that it's like
you have so much visual experience in
front of you like how did you 30 40 days
later you guys are worshiping around a
golden calf but let me tell you
something that that I've learned over
the years how much information do we
have but but not only that we have just
as most as much closeness as they as
they have actually even closer because
we have the Holy Spirit and we know the
beginning the end the middle the
everything in between and it's like they
didn't maybe have all those perspectives
together they're looking at this crazy
thing and maybe Egypt was a very Ault
civilization and had some magical junk
that they grew up seeing so maybe it
wasn't as Stark to them I don't know but
but to us we have no excuse I think we
have more evidence today than even those
people back then right the word of God
the word of God and uh I do have a
series where I talk about how the
Sanctuary is the centerpiece the of of
the whole scriptures if you search and
find it is the centerpiece of all these
stories whether it's um you know Daniel
and he's in Babylon and he's praying
towards the temple or um even even the
Garden of Eden was the original Temple
that dwelling uh intimate place where
they met uh in the Garden of Eden and
then there was the gate at the after
they sinned and they had the rudimentary
um alter of sacrifice there at the
Garden and and it just goes all the way
through that that Sanctuary is the
centerpiece um and we have so much
evidence through the scriptures like
you're say it's interesting because if
you you look at when they're they're
taken out you see the separation they're
no longer in the Holy place but what do
you see at the entrance to Eden you see
two
angels right and a flaming sword yeah
right in Revelation and Jesus identifies
himself as the one with a sword coming
out of his mouth what are you seeing
you're seeing a picture of God flanked
by two angels which is in the most holy
place right very good fantastic and you
know you're just you're I know we're not
even getting into this and it's probably
going to be a long conversation if we
don't get into this but but but we're
the sanctuary right yes and so it's like
all of a sudden you're you're you're
talking about this Central piece but
it's really it's really dealing with
this this is the physical view of of
what God want to do inside of here well
it's bringing us back to where we should
have been in the beginning because the
thing was you know if if you know with
you saying I don't know how they had the
most the the most evidence of who God
was yet they rejected god well I mean to
be in a garden I mean you know wasn't no
extreme cold wasn't no Extreme Hot you
didn't have allergies you know you're
not sneezing and snorting and everything
else you know if I was in the middle of
a garden there's no telling right now
what would happen around March but you
know they're in this garden they're
completely covered by God they have all
their needs met not just physically
because a lot of times when we think
about needs we think about physical but
this is emotional needs to be able to
talk to God every single day in the
morning and the evening him walking with
you through a whole garden and then and
then you listen to a serpent and so God
has to bring us back in every way to
where we originally were and now we're
doing it with him and to me is even more
intimate because he's we have to believe
even though we do not
see and that creates a greater intimacy
you're bringing out a really good point
because they were as much as we don't
think about it they were living their
life by faith how do we know that well
they're living by faith because they
believe God is who he is they believed
everything that God has told them mhm
right and then the serpent come along
when he comes along he offers the fruit
under the context of well I ate it and I
didn't die so if God told you that you
would die how do you know everything
else he's telling you is
true that's essentially their downfall
yeah I think that's how he approaches us
with every single topic everything and
so then you know now there's the
question doubt comes in and they're then
they stop living by faith because
they're not they're starting to question
the word the trust has has been broken
trust has been broken yes absolutely and
trust is the basis of everything that's
the first step developmentally for uh
babies and children is that trust
relationship between them and their
caregiver um and we know that that's so
often broken in our lives that um the
who have had deep wounds from childhood
and yet Jesus wants to say you can trust
me and you can bond with me I've got
everything and and we have found that
the steps in the sanctuary are emotional
steps to Healing all seven steps
emotional steps to Healing it's an
interesting example because as we're
talking about the application of
boundaries we can also talk about the
application of
healing so
with a baby they don't know any
different You're Building trust all
along the way by the demonstration of
love the same thing that God does with
us right before we can even be reasoned
with you look at the ministry of Jesus
he goes with the people he hangs out
with them he listens to them he
sympathizes with them he starts
ministering to their needs and then he's
like okay now let me teach you something
but that came way later yeah ministered
to all the needs first just like we do
with our kids like I mean you pour out
your life for your kid you're
ministering to their needs yeah and then
you're asking them Hey listen to
me very true and that's really what what
boundaries setting boundaries in the
sanctuary is all about is first meeting
other people's needs the way Jesus does
for us we've got to get grounded in
Christ and get rooted in him and feel
his love and protection and safety
around us and then we need to be like
Christ and go out and minister to others
and put them first put their needs first
and be willing to listen and then we can
work with them they can work with us
when we have to set a boundary um and
you know it it just brings me back to
all I just talking
to women in in counseling and talking to
them about their marriage and helping
them to understand how to meet meet the
need of their spouse you know
emotionally how to meet the needs and
you get so I I get so much push back
I've had clients just straight up cancel
me after the first session um because
they get so upset the minute I
say you the the only way that this is
going to work this is the only way it's
going to work you and and you're
probably not going to like me after this
but just think about it is you have to
learn how to meet his needs when you you
learn how to meet his needs then you're
going to be more outward focused and
he's going to give back when I get when
I tell that it shuts people down because
they want you to just they want me to
tell them how to get the other
person to meet their needs how do I
force him to do what it is I want why
can't he just do what I want him to do I
don't have time to meet his needs he's a
man he can meet his own needs I don't
have time for that but this let me let
me just tell you tell you this is the
only thing that works there is nothing
else there is no other if you want
something that works if you want a
counterfeit then you then you're then
you're headed in a different direction
but if you really want the real thing
for there to be Harmony in the
relationship and it goes with all
relationships you got to be willing to
lay your life down and meet the other
person's need that's the best
relationship is if you can try and out
love each other and we all have
different things that we need right
instead of looking at it what is this
person going to do for me it's what can
I do for this person to to make their
life more pleasurable them more happy
them more peaceful and it may be like
something that you know like I love like
when you study out the Love Languages
you know like someone's love language
just might be simple words of
affirmation right we can shower them
with gifts all you want and that doesn't
really do it to them right but if you
give oh that that's what that person
needs or wants and then you start giving
to that person and you know maybe maybe
the other person's physical touch or
whatever you know it's like when you
begin to understand what those
relationships are and how can I help
that other person that's when the
relationship begins to thrive but when
we have roots and we have emotional pain
it's very hard to even think about what
somebody else needs y um it's hard to
comprehend that uh because when we have
emotional needs that we have uh that
have not been met it's almost like we're
still a baby sucking on the bottle you
know and when you're a bab when you're
at a baby stage babies do not want to
meet any needs they don't they can't
comprehend that I'm cold I'm hungry feed
me it's all about them it's all about
them and many of us are at a baby stage
emotionally yeah we don't know and
cannot comprehend and don't want to and
are not going to meet anybody else's
needs and so we have to grow spiritually
with God and when we grow spiritually
with him and we yoke up with him and he
starts to meet our needs then he will
mature us and then we can get to more of
a you know the teenagers they don't meet
your needs all the time but they give a
little more they'll say Mommy I love you
you they may come give you a hug but
when you get to adult stage then you
really want to you you you got to get
out and you got to adult you start to
give back to the world and so that's
what God does to spiritually amen
absolutely and we can all recognize in
our hearts where our needs are and if
we're in a relationship where there's a
lot of issues and um we're drained and
empty it's hard to imagine how am I
going to get my needs met you know I'm
I'm done you know that kind of thing and
that's where God is calling us to the
sanctuary um and David talks so many
times in Psalms about how he wants to go
into the temple into the sanctuary and
meet God there and that's what we need
because we are empty empty vessels and
if we don't fill up day by day in Christ
it it's it's a struggle and that's where
these steps in the sanctuary now can be
very helpful for us to to grow in Christ
to grow up in Christ and if we are
looking to other
people we're going to have issues Jesus
says look to me look to that serpent
that was lifted up
um you've been bitten you've got poison
running through your system you've been
bitten by the snake and now we need to
just look to me and that really when
we're looking to other people we turn
them into an idol and God says they
shall have no other gods before me and
if we're looking to them to meet our
needs like a like a baby to a mommy or a
daddy we've got we've got struggles
going there good good point and I just
want to throw this out there because you
know some of our audience may be at
totally different walk of Life some
people just stumble across a video and
they're at the start of this thing what
they know of Christianity is a bunch of
broken people and and I think what
you're saying is so true and so
important don't look at the the
Christianity as as this is what God is
about the Christianity is whether we're
our worst enemy we have to keep our eyes
fixated on God and and obviously the
devil's working the hardest on his enemy
his enemy is the Christian so he's got a
legion of attack against those people
that's why the church is so messed up
and that's why there's so many different
things but that doesn't change the truth
about God Amen when we keep our eyes on
him amen well see the thing is and
that's a good point that you make that
we tend to it seems to be
interchangeable as because we have put
people at a place in our lot in our
heart where they shouldn't be we see
them as God and so we tend to think
that's how God is right and then it
makes you want to shut everyone else out
I mean somebody look at you a certain
way or say one thing to you in church
you don't want to come to church ever
again right it happens a lot yeah it
does unfortunately because we put people
on a pedestal and um you know if if
somebody doesn't know even how to get
their needs met how do you expect them
to know how to meet yours we don't I
half the time I don't know why I'm
thinking the way I'm thinking I know I
have a thought and I know that I how I
know how I feel but I don't know why MH
you know it's only your creator who can
be your recreator nobody can tell tell
you why you feel the way you feel and
nobody can meet the need for why you
feel the way you feel I think that
sounds like a t-shirt I
know be recreator yes yes absolutely
Jesus is is the answer we got to fix our
eyes on him uh to get filled up and
these steps in the sanctuary help us to
understand break it down to understand
him better otherwise it can be just oh
Jesus yeah and go throughout our day and
and not know how to really connect with
him and and just like Moses was able to
hear God's voice so clearly that these
Sanctuary steps are going to open our
ears and our hearts and our minds to him
and so um very quickly here we have
seven steps seven steps of perfection to
be able to bond with Jesus and we also
have the courtyard and the holy place
and the most holy place and this is a
template for intimacy that grows it
starts out um on maybe a less page and
then grows and grows to a deep page and
not only is this a template for intimacy
with God and getting our needs met with
him but also a template for intimacy and
relationships with people and you'll
notice there are boundaries that are set
up here in this template that God wants
us to have that those boundaries because
boundaries provide safety they provide
provides safety and um and and defines
also who we are our our blueprint of of
how God made us who God made us defines
who we are and we need that safe place
and the sanctuary is a safe place um it
and it says in in Psalm 91 it talks
about which refers to the the sanctuary
talks about how um this is a safe place
a refuge um where we can run to and go
to to find that safety and that safety
includes that bonded relationship with
God where we know who we are in Christ
and the trouble is is if we're looking
to others to find out who we are and if
we're okay and if we're loved and
accepted that can be instable you know
it's like building on the sand you can
build on the sand there's some firmness
to it but let a storm come and now it's
going to wash away we want our Temple
our foundation built on the Rock Jesus
Christ amen so these steps um include a
very important one at the beginning the
gates of praise and we don't want to
miss this one uh we we're not going to
go into each one deeply but just to say
that this first one the gates of Praise
Is it's it's extremely important for
mental health it really really is
emotional mental spiritual health praise
and this is not just about oh God needs
to hear me praising him all the time
it's it's helps us to recognize and
build our faith and trust in him as we
recognize how awesome he has been to us
praise and thankfulness and to keep us
um positive about what he is capable of
doing right now for me what he is
capable of doing in my future praise is
the most important thing you can do to
build that Mustard Seed of Faith amen is
to Waters that Mustard Seed of Faith
because it's like wait a minute he did
help me with this that and the other he
has provided this that and the other
maybe he can help me now I'm not on my
own he is here with me and these Gates
of Praise also
include um his love for us that he is
also loving us at the gates of Praise
it's not just going One Direction ction
because in John chapter 10 he says I am
the gate so that means he's full of
praise and he's full of goodness and
affirmation for us and it's not just a
one-way Street this is who he is and so
we um it's also the language of heaven
and so as we connect with that it is
going to build our um our mental health
our spiritual health and our growth and
and there's a lot out there in non
Christian circles about um being
positive an attitude of gratitude that
that is it's a law of our being because
we are a temple and this is the gate
into our Temple I mean you think about
every single thing that you like or that
you do you go I like that thing and then
you're going to move towards it right so
the initial beginning stages of any
relationship is you remember when you're
in grade school and it's like oh so and
so likes you you know what I mean and
that's that's what kind of the initial
beginning stage of you of you in into
somebody else is is like so it makes
sense that that would be the the first
step hey I I God I appreciate what you
do for me and then bam you're in these
Gates Philippians 4:6 says be anxious
for nothing but in everything by prayer
and supplication with Thanksgiving let
your request be made known to God yeah
and it's just so interesting that the
world has created a counterfeit for each
one of these steps and when you talk
about attitude or gratitude and making
all these lists and all these other
things um that's great and and and is
necessary but when you're doing that
without the presence of God it's only
it's only so far as far as emotionally
that you're going to be able to get but
when you have Jesus dwelling in your
mind and you're going through this this
process of Praise in your mind and
making yourself making your thoughts
obey the word of God bringing your every
thought under to the subjection of of
Christ there's so much power that can
happen in your mind and so much
emotional healing when you force
yourself to believe the truth about God
and to worship him in that it brings
about complete mental healing and it's
unfortunate because those who are not
are only just you know attitude of
gratitude they're just getting a small
smidget of what God could really do mhm
absolutely and that's because they don't
realize that the Bible says in Isaiah 28
that there is a battle at the gate
because the enemy is right outside and
he is like a lion seeking whom he may
devour and he does not want us to come
in through that Gates of praise and so
he's there trying to steal the Sheep so
to speak and so um we need to stay uh
connected with Christ in that and I want
to read um Psalm 100 just to direct our
minds there that that uh Psalm 100:4
says enter his great gates with
Thanksgiving and his courts with praise
give thanks to him and praise His name
almost the same thing as the New
Testament absolutely and so um but this
is harder than it looks at first because
um the enemy is the accuser he's the
opposite of Prayer in every way he's
discouragement yes and and he has been
trying to take us down for a long time
and even back when we're babies and when
we're children he's trying to attack us
with accusations negativity and what
I've discovered is that everything
positive is from God everything negative
is from the devil and even as Christians
we think that guilt is from God but
that's it's not God convicts us but he
does not put guilt or shame
condemnation blaming criticism none of
those things are from God he's inviting
us before we even come to the altar of
sacrifices step number two where Christ
died for us on the cross at the altar of
sacrifice he was fulfilling every aspect
of this Sanctuary the whole Plan of
Salvation is right in the sanctuary but
before we come to the altar of sacrif
where he was the Lamb of God that taketh
away the sin of the world um is those
pray is the praise and he is saying I
love you my child don't you listen to
the enemy that's saying negative things
to you every moment of the day that's
not my voice my voice is
love and affirmation and kindness to you
and there's hope all faith hope and love
and they' build one upon the other the
infinite
value that heaven offered for our
Salvation I don't think we have a
possibility to comprehend this like like
no spiritual being in heaven No Angel no
demon nobody none of them have ever died
Jesus only one we they they've seen
humans come and go all day long no
spiritual being has ever died and so
when Jesus stepped on and said I'll be
willing to take this price and if I
don't make it through here so be it I'd
rather not exist so you have an
opportunity to live the best of heaven
was given right there and that's I love
it that it's in the beginning of this
whole message it's not the end thing
that you find out it's like the first
thing you find out when you walk in
those Gates laying down your life right
absolutely and he's just the opposite of
Satan MH that he was willing to willing
to go the nth degree to lay his life
down in order to save us and the enemy
only wants to kill us and we're in a
culture right now where it's all about
selflove you know I mean self Lov is the
thing just all you got to do is just
love yourself we need to stop focusing
on oursel I told look I told my client
that and he did not get it right I told
we you you don't he's like I just need
to love myself and I said no you don't
you need to stop thinking about yourself
and you need to go to church I ended up
getting him in church in a Bible study
and they ended up talking about the same
topic in this men's group that he was in
they start they talked about self- Lov
and he came back to me few months later
which was recently and he said I get it
now I don't need to love myself I said
exactly cuz he just was not
comprehending it picture at the end of
the Bible right is they love not their
lives even unto death like like God
wouldn't tell you if that's the whole
purpose of life is so you just need to
love yourself
more would the end time people that he's
that he's promising are going to end up
here they could care less about their
own life right they would rather die
than defile God Amen and they think they
also realize that they have the hope
that you know you look at those
different churches of of Revelation
Jesus is identifying himself as the one
who did die and is alive forever more so
they're looking at this with also a hope
and a confidence like so what you're
going to kill me big deal take my body
can't take my
I know somebody who can take care of
that so whatever he who's willing to
lose his life will gain that is the
ultimate gain yeah amen amen praise God
and and and we want to connect with his
love not look to self or an inner
something for that we want to look to
him right at the beginning at the gates
of praise and his affirmation and love
towards us and then come in to the altar
of sacrifice where we can um humble
ourselves before for the Lord and ask if
him to help us with all of our problems
because he's a problem solver and he
fixes that problem all problems at the
cross there to die and and fix our
problem in love for us
not um in condemnation he died on the
cross full of love as he was sharing his
blood with us for that blood transfusion
yeah it was a you know who wants to give
their blood to somebody that they don't
love they're nailing his hands to a tree
and he's praying Lord don't don't get
mad at them I don't know what they're
doing that's that that's mindboggling in
the human experience you're praying for
the guy that is as he's murdering you
that's incredible that's love yes and so
he pours out his love to us and then we
can just confess our sins and he's
faithful and just to forgive us of our
sins and that he can bring about
conviction but he's not bringing
condemnation yeah and we can be
convicted and then we leave it all
behind and to be burned up on the altar
of sacrifice you know with Jesus uh
sacrificed there for us and that
intimacy grows as we can comprehend more
and more about his love then the labor
has um uh is about baptism but it's also
in Ephesians chapter 5 it says that he
wants to wash his bride wash us with the
water of his word yeah so he wants to
develop
communication with us that's what this
whole thing is about is communication he
communicated with Moses right he can
communicate with us it's all here
prepared for us and so he wants to
communicate with us so that we can hear
his voice better and be in tune with him
and as soon as he's speaking those
loving things to us it's like life it's
life and death and and that's what we're
looking for not self-love but God's love
and the word of God is um filled with
his thoughts and feelings filled with
his mind and his brain and he wants to
share that with us and the more we read
the more we can hear his voice um
throughout the day even if we're not
reading a Bible verse right then but he
can speak to our hearts and really
encourage and fill us with his love and
that intimacy grows now we can be filled
with the Holy Spirit at the um seven
Branch
Candlestick um as his Spirit fills us we
that's the new spirit-led life and we
think about Jesus when he was baptized
he raised up in the Dove he was filled
Anointed with the Holy Spirit and the
the fruits of the spirit are love joy
peace patience kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness self-control and
these seven aspects are wisdom knowledge
understanding counsel power fear of the
Lord discernment or good judgment so we
can be filled with all these things as
we grow up in Christ
and then we bond with him the table of
showbread he says I am the bread of life
unless you eat my flesh and drink my
blood you can't have part with me and
he's saying I want you to um uh eat my
words in later in that chapter talks
about how you eat my words they are
spirit and they are life in verse 63 and
so he wants us to eat um of his life so
that we will think like he does what
would Jesus do
and in a special way at the table of
showbread we can say what it what Jesus
walked this life before me how does he
want to help me now he's been through
every experience that I could ever
imagine or go through and way more and
he has the answer for me and we can talk
to him about it he can fix all of our
problems like he did for Moses and solve
all those problems and to um be filled
up with Christ and and that's um the
bonding gets deeper and deeper as we
dwell in this Sanctuary with him then
the altar of incense is where um is
where that we have prayer and prayer is
just communication with our best friend
Jesus and that he hears our prayers that
incense goes up and fills the whole room
and goes into the most holy place that
incense of our thoughts and our feelings
and our prayers as we are with him and
bonding with him laying everything all
of our concerns at his feet and then
listening like Samuel we don't have to
even be a grown-up we can be a child and
God spoke to Samuel because he was
willing to listen and Samuel was in the
sanctuary a lot too and then the Ark of
the Covenant he wants to make a New
Covenant with us a new life he has the
tablets uh with the law he wants to
write his law on our hearts because it's
about his heart of love and he wants
that heart of love to be on our heart
written with his finger not just tablets
of stone but on our hearts that intimacy
and on our minds he wants to write his
law on our minds so that we think like
him and we're in agreement with him
Holiness is agreement with God and so we
see the holy Place Most Holy Place
becoming more and more in agreement and
then trusting him for our daily food
with the Mana that's in the ark and
trusting him with authority that's
another whole topic that is really deep
that that Rod is a rod of authority who
was the authority that was leading and
we've had authorities put in our life
our parents and we have issues with what
happened to us in our childhood with
authority and Jesus wants to say I can
heal of you that of those things and you
can connect with me as your ultimate
Authority and and I will uh fill all of
your needs that your authorities were
not not able to do and I I'm I will help
you to be able to forgive your parents
which is healing as long as we're angry
with them we don't heal but he can give
us that ability to heal from anything
that's happened between us and
authorities that were not like Christ
and and put his authority in our lives
so um this is a a deep intimate Walk
With Jesus that he wants to have with us
but also it's the Pathway to have
intimacy with each other and that is um
where we want to kind of step into now
this is talking about um that I wrote on
here behaviors thoughts and feelings and
motives
so uh each compartment since we are a
temple and that's in first uh
Corinthians chapter 6 and chapter 3 it
says that we are God's Temple and the
temple is in exactly the same format as
this Tabernacle or the sanctuary all
seven steps are present and we also have
those seven steps in us and the
courtyard represents um our behaviors
the things on the outside of us um and
this is where people could come freely
into the
courtyard and but who were the only ones
that were allowed into the holy place
just the priest only the priests that
that's right so everybody's not to be
coming Willy nil into our holy place but
there will be people that mingle inside
the courtyard and as long as they're
following the right pathway and we'll
read that verse in a moment uh in this
um holy place is where our thoughts and
feelings that are inside of us can
anybody read our thoughts and feelings
no just God Only God and that's internal
that's inside of us inside our holy
Place only if we say them and share them
out loud would they come out into the
courtyard that's our choice we do not
have to share in the most holy place is
where our motives that are behind the
thoughts and feelings um that go all the
way back to our childhood our motives
all of the building blocks in our
childhood that made our character made
us who we are our belief system is all
formed in childhood and those motives uh
come out then into our daily thoughts
and feelings kind of like a computer
you've got the programs the hard drive
but then you have what's out on the
desktop you know or thing a programs
that's running currently running yeah
and um that's our current thoughts and
feelings and we don't realize how much
our thoughts and feelings are based on
things that happened to us from the past
and we're being triggered by that the
belief system what is true what is false
that hard drive mhm absolutely and so
God wants to cleanse our soul Temple as
we walk with him in the sanctuary um so
that our thoughts and feelings are like
his thoughts and feelings and he wants
to heal us from the wounds of the past
as well those deep things that hurt us
and caused our motives to be wrong he
wants to heal that not as a uh critical
judge that's putting us down but as our
savior and as our Good Shepherd and our
healer praise God for that before you
move on I want to mention that this is
really a experience that you're going to
have in your in your Christianity um
I've heard it like distilled down in
this way that the first step is you
really to realize that you're in need of
a savior which the reason when you come
to the very first article in there is
Jesus being sacrificed right you that's
the first thing that you you just got to
kind of like you know once you once you
get through Gates you realize okay I
need some help here then once you have
that experience you get Washed by the
labor and once you get Washed by the
labor you you're you're you're
spiritually moved into um you know the
Bible study um the prayer which is this
which is the incense and your witnessing
aspect right so you have these three
elements of prayer witnessing and Bible
studying I I like the idea of bringing
out the witness component because um
it's like anything you're teacher right
best way to teach somebody something is
go teach somebody else like you don't
know the information if you can't te
somebody else you don't know the
information the only way you can teach
them is if that you actually know this
right so when you have prayer Bible
study and witness you then are brought
into this close intimate relationship
where you have the the law written on
your heart and and it's like I love it
it's it's this kindergarten picture I
mean God I can't wait to meet God like
he's so he's so uh let me give you a
little illustration here and take you to
school and this is exactly what this is
yes it's beautiful absolutely I love
that I love that description the way
you've Reverb alized is powerful very
powerful and when you were saying
Witnesses the candlesticks that's our
light shining you know and and even
though yes it represents the Holy Spirit
but we need to be Spirit-filled and then
we will shine like a light and the way
that they had the Gold Room I mean that
was to Dazzle and show you how that was
bouncing around I mean it must have been
gorgeous to be inside of there you know
absolutely all gold beautiful here we
have a little deeper view of thinking
about the courtyard as being our body
the uh holy place is our spirit and the
most holy places our soul and when we
look at the motives here we've got those
emotional roots that go back to
Childhood that Jesus wants to heal so
that we uh can be more Christlike as we
know and it's always going to be about
God's love versus rejection because the
enemy of our souls has been plaguing us
with accusations That's what Satan means
accuser of the Brethren he's been doing
that for forever and in our lives and so
Jesus just wants to change those lies of
accusation into the truth of his love
and because of traumatic experiences we
believe it we believe the lies the
father of lives the enemy of our soul
and Jesus wants to rescue us that we
believe the truth and his truth is
always positive and always love that's
the encouraging thing he wants to bring
us back to reprogram our hard drive with
nothing but the loving Truth The
Sanctuary is Jesus said I am the way and
the truth and the life and that truth
brings us back to life and lies always
take us to death always down the wrong
path that way and Jesus says come in
here where it's safe the safe place of
for your soul
and I will uh Rec recreate your soul
restore your soul Psalm
23 uh goes completely over these steps
uh of bonding in the sanctuary praise
God so um that would be for a study of
another time but I I like the idea that
there's this there's this um fence
around here um I've always you know
thought about in heaven you have this
wall this huge wall wh why why the wall
What What In Heaven would you need to
protect at all why is there Gates right
I think psychologically God is just is
just showing us that he's protecting us
it's him that's going to keep the
universe safe and amen you know it's
just kind of this neat like mental
illustration that every time we walk
through those Gates ah yes I remember I
remember what happened down here and you
know like God you're my protection they
transparent mhm like gold yes yeah true
walls are clear you can see through them
and yet there's this never thought of
that
before true well I also think about um
have you ever seen how they start I've
seen like YouTube videos where they
start out on the earth and then they
they go back zoom out into the you into
space and then they zoom out even
further and they keep zooming out and
zooming out and zooming out until the
like the Earth becomes this minutia of a
galaxy and it's the whole entire
universe is based on boundaries MH all
these I mean there are bill would they
say billions of galaxies yeah I mean
everything is based on boundaries it's
pretty coely absolutely and and part of
it in a in a sinless universe and a
sinless world part of of what boundaries
are for as defining our our the
blueprint of what it is that's created a
tree has bark as its as its boundary and
you know what a tree is by its shape and
a cell has a boundary all around it and
so it's defining what that thing is and
we have these boundaries of who we are
and what is important to us what are our
thoughts and feelings uh what is you
know my um type of personality and it's
important to God and he wants to
preserve that and unfortunately the
enemy wants to break it down he's always
trying to break temples down as we know
and just you know even Jesus said um you
know destroy this Temple and I will
raise it in three days he was talking
about his body and who he was he was a
Temple and so God wants to preserve your
blueprint and he needs um to have those
boundaries set and it's okay sometimes
we feel guilty like we have to do what
everybody tells us to do
you know this and that and some people
are more people pleasing than others and
and without realizing that God wanted
you to to be who you are and it's okay
if you have a different opinion a
different
um concept than somebody else they don't
have to agree with you it's okay you can
set your boundary and express where you
are at yeah it's important to know where
your identity comes from lots of people
Define their identity by their job or by
what they eat or whatever but identity
can only be defined in Christ if it's
defined by anything else or if you
choose to be the one to Define it it's
always going to be off guilter yeah yes
absolutely has to be defined by God yeah
that's I me that was Satan's original
argument I don't need your laws I don't
need your things to tell us Holy Angels
where our boundaries are first identity
crisis there you go absolutely that's
beautiful that's beautiful and so God
wants us to know how to preserve these
boundaries in a sinful world because
there is a battle at the gate and we'll
just read um John chapter 10 and show
that how we know whether we are supposed
to let somebody in our
Sanctuary so John chapter 10 is where
Jesus is talking about himself being the
gate and he starts out in verse one I
tell you the truth the man who does not
enter the Sheep pen by the gate but
climbs in by some other way is a thief
and a robber the mind being like the
shakina of Glory this is where the the
Holy Spirit resides right this where God
communicates with us and this where he
keeps another thing that's kind of
interesting is we we we know clearly
from the scriptures and from the word
that that demons can come inside of you
but it is unnatural for the demon to be
there it is not his place God is the
only one that is inside of his creation
No Angels Are Climbing inside of your
mind like that and it's interesting
because they're they're outside of their
bounds well the only reason why they're
outside of their bounds because they
have access and the reason why they get
access is because we have in some way
come into agreement we took the fence
down right and and and you
know when you're a child you come into a
agreement with things even as a child
you know your parents get on your nerves
I can't stand them I hate them that's
access you know so it's it's even going
back to those childhood thoughts now you
know you're young you only know so much
but we can still choose to come into
agreement with Christ even as a baby
Jesus all throughout from the womb on he
always stayed in in agreement with the
father MH and whenever we let those
guard our guard down mhm and we come
into agreement with the Enemy on
anything Satan has rights and he has
access to our mind in a certain area and
when he has access then what happens is
it causes negative
Roots those negative Roots stay with us
throughout our life until we make the
choice to cooperate with Jesus to come
into agreement with him you ever read um
You probably heard of the book Pilgrims
Progress by
youever read a book no the follow to
that there's another book called The
Holy
War and in the holy war he lays out um
he's talking about being in this city
and how to protect the city of course is
all like a parable or metaphor for
guarding the
gates of that you have the natural Gates
that you have you have eye Gates you
have ear Gates you have the mouth gate
MH right to all these senses they're
they're Gates right and so he's he's
trying to show how in the Christian
experience you need to guard and protect
those Gates which is a lot of what this
channel is
about but I just want to I just want to
to kind of wrap up that
thought the Bible when it talks about
the New Jerusalem when everything's
wrapped up right God makes this
statement that is a boundary defining
statement doesn't use the term boundary
doesn't use the term gate but the
principle is there he says but there
shall by no means enter in it anything
that defiles or causes an Abomination or
a lie but only those who are written in
the Lamb's Book of Life he's like in
Heaven There are
boundaries and there's not going to be
anything that comes in here amen that is
contrary to my kingdom okay it's all out
can I just apply this to our work for
right now cuz you're just like no go for
it I'm setting you up it's volleyball
I'm set I'm telling you I'm telling you
the work that we do is trying to get
people to understand like look when we
watch all of this evil how can this not
impact us think about the history of the
world right people didn't normally see
someone murdered in the world I mean you
you would only see that if you went to
war that's it and you you came back from
war you were messed up right um I just
spoke in front of 3,000 people and asked
the question how many of you have seen
um somebody die every hand went up and
it was just like look at the amount of
evil we put in front of our eyes on a
daily basis people lying stealing
cheating you name it just constantly
over and over and over breaking again to
the point with now many of our young
people are playing games where your
purpose of the game is to run around and
shoot and kill everybody so that you're
the only one standing in the
room I mean think of the boundaries of
evil that have been cracked down in our
generation I so look forward to a day
that we get to heaven that none of this
none of this is going to be there and
and I always tell young kids all the
time look look if you think you can do
this in Heaven by all means if you think
you're going to be watching and killing
and playing fortnite in heaven but if
you're not don't do it here what are we
doing it here for yes there's a lot of
things that are like that and you know
I've said this before especially in like
our little worships that work tell it to
people privately but there's there's the
beginning there was no sin things were
certain I mean God had a perfect way of
doing things there was there was he set
up marriage set up the Sabbath set up a
particular diet right did all these
things you look at the end you see all
those things again and somehow in the
middle we think uh it's supposed to be
different m or that it should be
different that's not God's plan God's
plan is it got ruined here I want to get
here the only way we get there is by
following his plan not by staying MH you
know where we're at that's not God's
ideal no he wants to he wants
restoration and one of the things that I
believe the Lord uses is parents he's
created parents as a bridge to help
children to hear the Holy Spirit um
they're not left desolate to try to
figure out how to connect with God on
their own but the problem is because of
all of the sin that's been infiltrated
and and and and the the worse you know
it's gotten so much worse over the
generations you know I mean we we didn't
have those types of video games when I
was a child and then my parents didn't
have those but things are just getting
drastically worse and so the parents are
being are now they're such an easy
target whereas before parents were a
guard to keep the children and helping
the children to grow in their
relationship with God now go Satan could
easily use the parents and then now we
have trauma we have emotional pain we
have all these things that are being
kind of um in introduced early at early
stages I mean sexual pedophilia all
these different things that are being
there's no safety for children anymore
there's no boundaries around them no and
so but but see and so God wants to heal
heal us so that now we can become um a
shield to our children but also heal us
of whatever trauma and whatever things
we experience because we didn't always
have that shield from our parents cuz
our parents you know your parents didn't
know some some things they just really
didn't know they did their best but
there was emotional pain and things that
got passed down sin gets passed down to
the third and the fourth generation and
some of the things that I've done my mom
did my mom's mom did and so the Lord
wants to heal not just us and our mind
but he wants to heal our entire family
line I heard Walter VI breaking down
epigenetics that I was just like it's
deep oh my goodness this stuff can pass
through the air to your child yes which
not and you know epigenetics we tend to
think of it as far as like okay if I if
I ate meat eat chances and I got
diabetes chances are my child will get
diabetes well just think how it relates
to the Mind yep you know if I have
sexual sin that's festering in my mind
and I don't get it right with the Lord
then I'm going to pass down that sexual
sin to my child and my child's child and
so if you think about just any type of
negative thought if you allow that thing
to Fester you will pass it down but the
thing is that there's
hope that if we choose no matter what
stage you're at if you choose to
cooperate with the Lord it doesn't
matter what happened in the past you can
create a whole new DNA right based on
you being healed with Christ and Christ
alone that's right cuz you died and
something else came up right I mean it's
a whole reparenting that he can do even
if the parent didn't come into agreement
with him he can reparent us all by
himself yes and then we are born again
with new epigenetics of Christ passing
all of his victories down to us yes full
victory in the sanctuary and it and it's
deep and um would take a long time to
and I have some messages um on the
sanctuary that talks about just each one
of the steps and the cleansing message
in the most holy Place how God wants to
do this work with this last
generation and um and it's called
Sanctuary Pathways and so you can look
that up on my website which which is
sanctuary for families the number four
beautiful okay Sanctuary the number four
families and I had to do that instead of
f because there's way too many websites
that are talking about sanctuaries for
families of abused children and and uh
Abused women that it's a sanctuary for
families and this is the ultimate
Sanctuary for All Families where we can
get that healing that's been passed down
through our family line and to have
epigenetics through the Holy Spirit from
Christ to renew our minds regenerate our
minds that God wants to do and that
final generation out of this world of
this age that is like as of the days of
Noah that's where we find um the
144,000 being mentioned that last
generation that walk with Christ in the
sanctuary they're safe in Christ in the
sanctuary and what does it say in
Revelation 14 verse um let's see four
let's start with these are those who did
not defile themselves with women for
they kept themselves pure and um that
includes uh the concept of women being a
church um or anything that is um
defiling that God wants to purify our
soul Temple from they follow the lamb
wherever he goes the the wedding supper
of the Lamb is before he even comes in
the clouds where we're bonding with him
right here in the Holy Place we've got a
wedding supper prepared for us at the
table of
showbread and then it says
um they were purchased from among men
and offered as first fruits to God and
the lamb we to be that that final group
that goes all the way it's like the
Baton has been passed down generation
after generation and that this group
want is God wants to take us to the
finish line and get us over the other
side and it says no lie was found in
their mouths they are
blameless and so even um though some of
this can get a little a little bit
confusing at times and seem like a whole
lot it all boils down that bottom line
is lies versus truth Satan is always
telling lies whether it's doctrinally or
whether it's about who you are from the
time you were little uh anything and
lies he speaks nothing but lies so
anything he says is lies that lead to
death and they're always going to be
negative so it's as simple as knowing
what is negative and what is positive
and Jesus has is always telling the
truth the truth will set you free you
will be Sanctified and cleansed when we
connect with all truth yeah there will
be no lies left as we get connected
fully with him and his truth communing
in the sanctuary staying connected
finding out what the truth is about who
I am about who other people are who God
is ETC then then he will cleanse and
purify Us by that truth and it's always
is going to be positive yeah and that
and healing that's going to heal our
soul and set us free from the bondage of
sin yeah I was going to say that you
know usually when that scripture is
referenced we think about um not being
defiled and being pure just as like the
physical context but when we think about
purity and virginity as it relates to
the mind being pure in your thinking um
only believing that truth not believing
those lies only coming into agreement in
your mind with truth only thinking
positively about others only being
outward focused towards others you're
not at all thinking about self the Lord
is going to get us to a point where
we're completely healed to where there's
no self-seeking in our mind we're
completely pure and we're not defile
absolutely beautifully said I like that
you're distilling it down to lies versus
truth do you think think about it if you
have another God well that's a lie
because that's not how that's not a
better way right having one God is is is
the way right all the way down to the
line if you steal right if I steal I'll
just have more stuff and I'll be more
happy right well that's that's a lie
that's not how you should live your life
if I just if I just commit adultery on
my on my wife right then then then I'll
be more happy that's a lie we know that
doesn't happen so it's an interesting
way to look at it like lies versus truth
true God's ways are true and just
basically what what everything gets
distilled down too with the Antichrist
power when it comes on the scene too in
second Thessalonians it says and with
all unrighteous deception among those
who perish because they did not receive
the love of the truth they might be
saved and for this reason God will send
them strong delusion that they should
believe the lie right oh wow that's
incredible incredible you easily come
under the lie and Satan has access when
you do not believe the truth mhm and in
and with all mental disorders I always
put that you know I always look at
things in a disorderly type of way
because I'm a therapist but you know
anytime we fall below praise you're
opening yourself up to all different
types of mental health disorders um
depression anxiety you know just the the
list goes on panic disorder all of these
different disorders they're a result of
not understanding how to stay in praise
and you see that
if I mean if you read the text closely
you really see that after the fall of
Man right now God's like walking in the
garden he's like where are you at Adam
it's not a geography question right you
know it's like where are we at
relationally Adam where are we at hiding
behind the bush yeah it's not like God
is bad at hide-and seek right right so
and then you start to see like there's
the blame game mhm there's there's
there's there's the anxiety there's the
depression there's like all of it just
starts flooding in and then we when we
talk about things getting passed down
and you look at Cain and Abel you know
they had just come out of this this
experience their parents had just come
out of this experience and then we have
these two children and then what happens
and the first thing that God asked Cain
when he went before after he killed Abel
he said where are you he asked him where
no it was before he killed Abel when he
was talking to him about the offering
and he said where are you why are you
angry why he said and so you know we see
that this is a direct result of them
just coming out of having this
experience all this different these
different feelings and emotions they had
that they came over that they didn't
work through now got passed down to the
Next Generation God had a boundary
worship like this he stepped outside of
that boundary right and said I'm going
to worship to be like I Want To Worship
You and God already defined the boundary
mhm and it's a crazy thought that the
very first child will not be in heaven
yeah I mean that's that's just a crazy
thought like at like Eve working with
100% of her brain basically we're we're
we're pretty pretty low on the totem
pole of function at this stage in
Earth's history and she lost her child
yeah the one she thought was going to be
the Messiah exactly exactly interesting
because all issues
eventually go back to you know from sin
that have to deal with the lies is
rejection and Eve felt very rejected and
Adam did too you know they were dis they
were disconnected yeah and and this
Sanctuary here is for bonding Unity
agreement it's all about being in
Harmony and agreement and now they are
separated because of sin not only from
God but from each other and all those
issues are going into Cain and and and
the anger that both of them are feeling
they knew what it was like to be in love
beforehand and now that's all changed
and so there's a lot of anger and
resentment it took him a while to like
Abel and Seth came along that they
worked things through more with God and
with each other but there was just so
much that was being passed down to Cain
in the womb about rejection and that's
the neat thing about healing again it's
that bottom line those those rejection
feelings you can name it you know a
thousand different names but it's all
whether you feel rejected or accepted
and loved or whether you're rejected and
and so um all rejection is lies from the
enemy and we still believe that we still
believe that there's that we're there's
something wrong with us or we got to
work our way into acceptance and re you
know with other people or with God and
he wants us to be Repro programmed with
the truth that we are loved we are
special he did not create something that
was a misfit he created our original
blueprints perfectly if we have the
correct picture of what the relationship
looks like right just think about that I
mean we talk about with young kids all
the time pornography right if you looked
at that as that's someone's daughter
what if that was your daughter what if
that's your sister what if that's your
mom you know what I mean does that
change the context of it Keith brought
up a really interesting point in in the
video games where they run around and
shoot people right you you feel so
disconnected from that because you don't
have that relationship picture correctly
what if you put your your family's faces
on them would you run around and shoot
your family what if you put Jesus's face
on it would you actually shoot Jesus in
the face that might totally change what
you do and it's like every relationship
we have to look at like what's the
what's the real relationship here you
know connecting you know us together
together it's when we feel disconnected
that we're we're able to do terrible
things to each other well part of it is
because our goal you know when we really
seek God said seek and you shall find
knock and the door will be open when
we're seeking after Jesus then he will
teach us and show us how to put people
in their right place but when we're
trying to get our acceptance through
people it it's just it never works it
only goes so far because people can show
you I mean I've been in situations where
there was a hundred things that the
person did right and one thing that they
did wrong or one thing that they did not
necessarily wrong but that I didn't like
and I can't even focus on those hundred
things I can only focus on that one
thing that wasn't done right nobody can
walk the line perfectly only Jesus
Pastor said this one thing I'm not going
back to J right but he had a whole
sermon right right you know and people
were so loving when you walked in and
were so nice they invited you to potluck
but one thing was said yeah you know and
so when we put people on the throne then
we're looking to get accepted through
them and our whole Paradigm has to shift
in order for us to really come into the
sanctuary we have to shift our Paradigm
I'm I'm reading I'm taking a class on
Revelation right now and the throne is
actually a huge issue in the Book of
Revelation and so when Satan is is
bringing forward his accusations to God
and it's all in the context of like
there seven hymns in Revelation you know
and Satan's kind of like this chord that
doesn't go with the other two chords of
Praise um he's really questioning
whether God has the right to sit on the
throne well I like that yeah that's deep
here's what's crazy Walter VI brought
this up this last weekend he goes Satan
wanted to sit on the throne that was his
argument right I I think I should be the
one that's sitting on the throne not you
like you need to get off and I need to
get on the throne right so what does God
do he produces a people over here and
then at the very end he says I'm going
to take these people and I'm going to
put them on my Throne can you imagine
why Satan hates us so much because the
very thing that he wanted God's
literally saying and and do you know
what I really think that is that's God
proving to the
universe that we have gone through such
an experience that we be safe enough for
him to put on the throne and we would
not repeat what we just went through now
look at how Satan continues to work
though he he has a throne The Book of
Revelation alludes to that he has a
throne how do we know that he shares his
throne with the beast wow right but why
does he share his throne so that he can
have control and power why does God
share his throne so he can not yeah yeah
lay down his life he's sharing out of
altruistic
motives not because he's trying to get
power Because by the time Jesus Takes
the Throne all power has already been
given to him so God is showing us a
picture of security yeah personal
security I'm I'm good Satan is showing
us a picture of insecurity as he works
through other entities to establish his
throne I love it love this topic is so
deep series yes yes we got to wrap it up
yes and it just reminds me um there's a
number of things that I want to say that
um are related for how we can set
boundaries but that will be for a
discussion of another time but just to
know that as we come into the sanctuary
and get our needs met and we feel
covered in Christ um there are there's a
a phrase in the Bible garments of praise
that we feel covered when there's
positivity when we feel that God is
loving us and and that we're doing the
right thing then we can stand on the
rock of Truth uh though the heavens fall
and we can stand for the boundaries that
God is wanting for uh for us to to have
and that as we uh connect and get all of
our needs met even our emotional needs
from past um in Christ that we are full
and ready to be able to really minister
to the other person um and listen to
them outward Focus to them and not have
to rush with what we want to say first
but but minister to them so that they
can hear us more clearly if we put them
first and we listen to them first they
can hear us more clearly when we do have
to set a boundary that is different and
it makes it feels painful because now
we're in disagreement but uh boundaries
are uh when are disagreement if we're in
agreement then you don't need a boundary
you know you're you're connected on that
you're walking together but if you're in
disagreement now a boundary is needed
and we need to feel secure in Christ on
uh built on the rock that um so that we
can stand though the heavens fall and I
just think that when you were talking
about these Thrones here uh Revelation
the leodan church where this 144,000 are
are coming out of leoda at the end it is
saying in uh verse 19 and onward it says
Those whom I love I rebuke and
discipline and that would kind of like
be at the altar of sacrifice where we
lay our lives down it says so be Earnest
and repent and so we repent there here I
am I stand at the door and knock if
anyone hears my voice so he's knocking
on our Temple door and he doesn't come
barging in he he he respects our
boundaries and our choices and he says
but if you do listen to my voice and
open the door for me then I will come in
and eat with him and he with me so we'd
be bonding here at the table of
showbread we're going to eat and sup
together we're going to be able to hear
his voice better and and he's going to
give us that peace he's going to tell us
the truth he's going to give us that
security all the love that we need he
has abundant for us there's absolutely
no rejection in him if there's ever a
time you feel rejected it's always from
Satan amen uh no matter what time of
life it came to you but he has always
has acceptance then it says to him who
overcomes and we'll overcome with Jesus
um and and I've thought about that in
chapter 12 Revelation 12 we overcome the
Enemy by the word of Our Testimony you
know what we H what we say is setting
that boundary
on on the enemy and when we overcome I
will give the right to sit with me on my
Throne just as I overcame and sat down
with my father on his throne so he is
opening that door to Intimacy in a way
that was probably more than Lucifer
because there's going to be that bride
relationship Jesus is human and we're
the bride and a bride and and grooms sit
together on a throne you know the king
and the queen sit together on that
throne not safe to sit on the throne if
you don't have boundaries amen
amen yeah that's really a beautiful
picture and and of course um Revelation
you might wonder like why does the leoan
church only get one gift it's because
that gift encompasses all the other
gifts that are promised to the other
churches so they're getting the whole
package when they get the right to sit
with the Lamb on the throne amen so I
hope that is your desire to sit with a
lamb on the throne in in a picture of
comfort and security I hope that you uh
have a desire to be secure in Jesus
maybe you're hurting and I think that's
probably a lot of people who are
watching this probably some of the
people that have sat at this table are
are hurting or have been hurting at one
point or another but there is security
and safety in Jesus and we've me
mentioned a couple of resources that you
can check out to learn more about this
and if you need to reach out to one of
these ladies you can let us know and we
can find a way to put you in contact
with them having said that make sure you
like comment subscribe to this video and
check out our merch on lightwear do shop
if you want to give and donate to this
ministry go to
ls. and you can help support programs
like this one thank you for watching and
we will see you next time on LED live
take
care do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey every day is an opportunity to
show kindness to the
[Music]
world every day is an opportunity to do
something now let someone know you're
thinking of
them every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in
[Music]
return every day is an opportunity to
notice someone in need and to go out of
your way to help
them every day is an opportunity so much
to do one small
thing to show someone you
care to make the world a better
[Music]
place
a